台湾艺人许效舜
他痛风痛了三十多年
可以说是活生生的
痛风代表
有一次他到澳门吃明虾
隔天啊
痛风发作
脚痛到站都站不起来了
吃止痛药也没有用
最后只能坐轮椅
搭飞机回台湾
在医院里住了
整整九天才出院
想避免痛风复发吗
来喝这一杯OO
降低痛风风险
等一下马上告诉你
胡乃文开讲啰
我是你的老朋友胡医师
这一集要和你分享
喝1杯饮料降4成痛风的风险
痛风发作1穴位吃2水果止痛
1碗台湾小吃降尿酸三高
不吃海鲜也痛风？
喝1杯降4成痛风风险
台湾有痛风的人口
接近百万
这数字可真是吓人啊
想预防痛风
来每天喝一杯牛奶
新英格兰医学期刊指出
每天喝乳制品的人
得到痛风的机会
能够降低百分之
44%
但是提醒你
牛奶不要喝太冰的喔
牛奶的乳清蛋白
能让尿酸溶解顺利的排出
而它的酪蛋白呢
加速乳酸排泄
间接的让
尿酸也跟着排出去了
诶有粉丝问我
胡医师啊
我不喝牛奶怎么办
没关系不喝牛奶的人
你吃无糖的优格
哎也是可以的
痛风是中年人
才会得的病吗
不是
现在甚至连国小生
都得到痛风了
是真的吗太离谱了
是真的一位八岁的小男生
经常吃卤肉饭
把自己养得是白白胖胖的
有一天走路突然跛脚了
一检查发现
竟然是痛风发作
还合并其他的慢性病
真的让人是捏一大把冷汗啊
痛风不只是会找上
爱吃大鱼大肉喝酒
或肥胖的男性
这两种人也得要注意喔
爱喝含糖饮料的人
停经之后的女性
小编啊
你每天都在喝饮料
你要给我注意喔
好喔医师
我会从一个礼拜
喝7杯饮料
改成6杯半
一半分给同事
哇
少喝点
小编啊你知道吗
每天喝500cc含糖饮料的人
含糖饮料里的
高果糖玉米糖浆
会阻碍尿酸的排出
停经以后还没有喔你没有
停经以后的女性
因为雌激素的下降
尿酸代谢就变慢了
痛风风险
也会大幅的增加喔
痛风不好好治疗
会面临什么问题
洗肾洗腰子啊
尿酸太多会沉积在关节
让你肿得难受痛到抓狂
时间久了肾脏也开始受损
万一更严重的话
很可能就要
洗肾了
那个时候伤身花钱
又花很多的时间
是不是得不偿失啊
半夜痛风发作？
1穴止痛补肾
用这两招快速消除痛风
第一招
你先用毛巾包裹着冰块
敷在肿的地方来止痛
第二招按1个穴
按什么呢
太溪穴
太溪穴可厉害了
急性痛风
你按这个穴位
它能够缓解疼痛
慢性期来按太溪穴能够补肾
太溪穴在哪个地方啊
在内踝尖和后头的
阿基里斯腱之间的
那个凹陷的洞洞里面
那个就是
你现在就可以边按边听我
慢慢的跟你道来
太溪穴不只是能够止痛
它的功效还真是不少
能调整肾气虚
导致的尿酸代谢失衡
它是肾经的非常大的大穴
你是属于痛风
尿酸过高的人
平时就多按揉这个穴位
它能从根本调整肾气
将毒素排出体外
让痛风不再半夜和你纠缠
2水果止关节肿痛
喝豆浆会引起痛风？
痛风的人
你是不是会担心喝了豆浆
吃了豆干会让痛风更严重别
担心
其实是在急性期的时候
不能吃豆制品
在慢性期
豆腐豆干豆浆
这些都还可以正常吃
来我来教你
急性慢性痛风饮食怎么吃
让你快快远离痛风
先说第一部份
急性期
当你关节痛得很厉害
痛风发作时候
来吃两种水果
1 樱桃2 蓝莓
樱桃和蓝莓啊
有植化素和多酚
能减少尿酸结晶的形成
抗发炎
对于关节疼痛
特别有帮助
研究发现
每天吃10到12颗樱桃
或者是一小碗的蓝莓
大概是女生的拳头
这么大小的一份
能够减少痛风
反覆发作的风险
但不是吃越多越好啊
吃多了反而糖份太高了
那急性期不能吃哪些食物
四类食物先暂停
1.肉类
像红肉
例如牛肉羊肉猪的红肉
2.海鲜3.酒类
4.高普林的食物
鱼皮小鱼干内脏
还有很浓的火锅汤
鸡精这些汤
还有就是
这些蔬菜
豆苗豆芽芦笋香菇紫菜
也先不要吃
这些食材
它的核酸的含量比较高
容易提高尿酸
再来讲慢性期
你的饮食
可以慢慢回到正常
不过急性期
不能吃的食物
还是不要多吃哦
吃白肉鱼蛋豆制品
但是要记得
油炸的豆类还是不要吃
甜食酒类含糖饮料都要少碰
平常你喜欢辣粉胡椒粉
撒好撒满的
爱吃重口味的
你把口味调得淡一些
减轻肾脏的负担
最后喝水也很重要
多喝水可以降尿酸吗
可以
多喝水能够增加尿量
加速尿酸的排出
降低尿酸在关节里沉积的风险
有助于控制痛风
1碗小吃超神奇
降尿酸三高
中医治痛风
不但能把尿酸降下来
还会解决痛风
背后真正的问题
痛风是脾肾出了状况
痰湿堆积在体内
经络不通
关节就痛得受不了
想让痛风不复发
推荐你喝台湾小吃
四神汤
四神汤它有5个很棒的功效
1.健脾利湿
2.通经活络
3.降尿酸
4.健脾胃
5.降三高
哇真好
四神汤它的配方很简单
茯苓芡实莲子山药
台湾卖四神汤的店家
都会加个薏仁
薏仁就是这一碗汤的灵魂
神农本草经记载
薏仁能治肌肉僵硬
风湿痹痛
长期喝能轻身健体
增强力气
我有一个病人
78岁老太太
同时有痛风高血糖高血压
我建议他每天喝四神汤
两年之后痛风不再发作
血糖血压都稳定
生活品质大大提升
你知道吗
他到了90多岁
还能够坐公共汽车来看我
还有一位
海外的观众和我分享
他因为血糖太高
整天都昏昏沉沉
人很不舒服
喝了一周的四神汤之后
他一直降不下来的
那个血糖
竟然降下来了
更奇迹的是
血压也降了
人也清爽有精神多了
真是非常的棒吧
如果家里有三高的人
你可以每周喝两三次四神汤
帮你控制血糖血压
甚至小孩喝了还能养脾胃顾肾脏
有一个粉丝
很可爱留言问我
四神汤里面大部份
都是猪小肠猪肚
痛风的人
不是不能吃动物内脏吗
这不是相抵触了吗
没错台湾的小吃店卖四神汤
都会加猪肠猪肚
但是呢
你是痛风的候选人的话
那就还是自己煮四神汤
别买那样子的现成
煮了猪肠猪肚的四神汤好吧
腿红肿痛未必是痛风
辨证施治才对证哦
之前我看过一个病人
这个病腿又红又肿痛得要命
去医院看了
医生一直把他当痛风来治疗
治了几个星期都没治好
而且还痛得不行
最后还是来找到我
我一看就说
嗯这不是啊
这是蜂窝性组织炎
所以要注意啊
蜂窝性组织炎跟痛风
有一点点相似
痛风是长在关节上面为主
而蜂窝性组织炎
常常是皮肤发了炎了
细菌啊等等这些
经过组织
肌肉的组织而往上走
成为一整条或者一整片的
这红肿热痛
因为痛风跟蜂窝性组织炎
看起来很像
因此这个医生他的第一印象
认为这个红肿热痛就是痛风
可是蜂窝性组织炎它是感染
要用抗感染的治疗
错治就会拖病情对不对
所以别以为痛风老毛病又来了
然后自己就判断了
或者跟医生就讲
我这是痛风了
我们学中医的人看这些东西
都得要好好的辨证
到底它是属于什么样的问题
对症才会治疗有效
亲爱的粉丝们
我们已经开启会员频道了
如果你认同我推广中医
照顾自己健康的理念
欢迎每月小额支持
只要花两杯咖啡的钱喔
或成为VIP赞助者
有你同行
我们才能走得更远
真心感谢你哦